Before going into how single tape
machines can simulate multi-tape ones,
I want to warm up with a very simple
example to illustrate what we mean
when I say that one machine
can simulate another.
So let's consider what I'll
call stay-put machines.
These have the capability of not moving
their heads in a computation step.
Which turing machines as we defined
them are not allowed to do.
So the transition function
now includes a S for
the direction,
which makes the head stay put.
Now this doesn't add any computational
capability to the machine.
Because I can accomplish the same
things with a normal turing machine.
For every transition where the head
stays put, we can introduce a new state.
And just have the head move
one step to the right.
And then one step back to the left.
Gamma here means to match
everything in the tape alphabet.
And this puts the had back
in the spot it started in,
without affecting the tape's contents.
Except for occasionally taking
an extra movement step.
This turning machine will operate in
the same way as the stay put machine.
More precisely, we say that two machines
are equivalent if they accept the same
inputs, reject the same inputs and
loop on the same inputs.
If we consider the tape to be part of
the output equivalent machines also
need to halt with
the same tape contents.
Note that other properties
of the machine such as,
the number of states,
the tape alphabet, or
the number of steps in any given
computation do not need to be the same.
Just the relationship between the input
and the output needs to be the same.